wie bewerten sie denn den wahlausgang in
thüringen die wahl in thüringen gestern
war eine mischung aus amtsbonus für bodo
ramelow und großem misstrauensvotum
gegenüber der sogenannten großen
koalition in berlin ich habe das in
vielen veranstaltungen dort erlebt es
gibt wirklich großen unmut über cdu und
spd in ostdeutschland ganz besonders
aber ich glaube auch in deutschland
insgesamt
diese regierung wird halt abgestraft bei
solchen landtags vor allem gegen wen
richtet sich diese unmut konkret gegen
die person der kanzlerin gegen die
parteivorsitz für die parteivorsitzende
hat dabei nach meiner beobachtung
kaum eine negative rolle gespielt ganz
überwiegend steht die bundeskanzlerin im
mittelpunkt der kritik und von ihr wird
etwas erwartet was eigentlich jeder
staatsbürger in diesem land erwarten
kann nämlich politische führung und
klare aussagen ich nenne ihnen mal ein
beispiel seit monaten diskutiert diese
koalition über die grundrente und kommt
zu keinem ergebnis da jetzt einen
koalitionsvertrag da steht ausdrücklich
im koalitionsvertrag grundrente mit
bedürftigkeitsprüfung warum macht diese
koalition das nicht endlich und machte
offensichtlich immer weitere
zugeständnisse an die spd
die niemandem hilft der spd erkennbar
nicht der cdu aber auch nicht mike
mohring hat ja jetzt heute gesagt erst
das land dann die partei sich offen für
gespräche mit der linkspartei gezeigt
hat er darauf dass eine partei wie die
cdu eine einladung eines amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten an dem zu einem
gespräch ist aus meiner sicht
selbstverständlich eine ganz andere
frage ist ob daraus denn in irgendeiner
form eine zusammenarbeit werden kann
da hätte ich große vorbehalte eine
koalition meines erachtens ganz sicher
nicht aber in welcher form man dieses
land regierungsfähig erhält
ich finde da brauch mike mohring von
außen keine ratschläge das ist eine
schwere verantwortung die er dort im
land jetzt selbst trägt und da muss er
zunächst einmal ausloten was geht und
was nicht geht also notfall würden sie
sagen im notfall würde ich nicht sagen
dass es hier zu einer zusammenarbeit
kommen sollte das gilt für die
linkspartei wie für die afg aber wenn
eine solche situation eingetreten ist
dass in der politischen mitte überhaupt
keine mehrheiten mehr vorhanden sind
noch nicht einmal theoretische
mehrheiten faden sind dann muss man doch
wenigstens mit dem gewählten amtsinhaber
einmal reden können und dürfen wie das
land jetzt geführt werden kann und das
finde ich ist eine verantwortung die hat
mike mohring die kann einem niemand kann
ihm niemand abnehmen aber die sollte ihm
auch von außen nicht streitig gemacht
werden
nun beklagt ja schon sehr deutlich die
situation der bundes partei in
schlechten eindruck den die bundespartei
gemacht hat welche verantwortung würden
sie sagen trägt vielleicht doch auch
einen krieg kramp karrenbauer
wir sind in einer ganz schwierigen
situation
das hängt nach meinem eindruck aber vor
allem damit zusammen dass sich seit
jahren über dieses land wie eine wie ein
wie ein nebel teppich die die
untätigkeit und die mangelnde führung
durch die bundeskanzlerin legt das ist
der hauptkritikpunkt den ich wahrnehme
und den ich auch teile das kann so nicht
weitergehen und ich kann mir schlicht
nicht vorstellen dass diese art des
regierens in deutschland noch zwei jahre
dauert bis zum ende dieser wahlperiode
bis ende 20 21 das geht einfach nicht
dafür sind die probleme des landes zu
groß dafür sind aber auch die
internationalen herausforderungen viel
zu groß das kann sich deutschland das
kann sich aber auch europa nicht leisten
aber ist kramp-karrenbauer als märkten
vertraute wirklich die richtige um die
partei aus dem nebel wissen also wir
haben annegret kramp karrenbauer auf dem
bundesparteitag im letzten jahr gewählt
ich habe hier meine unterstützung
zugesagt dazu stehe ich und dazu stehe
ich auch ein schwerer
trotz der schlagzeilen gemacht hat ich
habe verständnis dafür dass sie sich
jetzt auch beklagt ich habe wenig
verständnis dafür dass es jetzt aus
geschlossenen sitzung heraus wieder
nachrichtenmeldungen gibt wir müssen das
intern miteinander besprechen auf dem
parteitag in leipzig offen aus
diskutieren und dann wird es hoffentlich
konsequenzen geben die entscheidungen
sind getroffen und bis auf weiteres sind
sie getroffen
sie stehen ich stehe dazu so wie ich das
vor einem jahr gesagt habe daran hat
sich nichts geändert wissen sie da sind
wir westfalen ziemlich stur wenn wir
einmal etwas zugesagt haben dann halten
box daran aber gut sein
selbstverständlich muss darüber
diskutieren aber noch einmal eine krieg
kam karrenbauer ist nicht die einzige
die hier im mittelpunkt der kritik zu
stehen hat sondern es gibt auch andere
und das gesamte erscheinungsbild der
deutschen bundesregierung ist einfach
grottenschlecht und daran muss sich
etwas ändern